sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager once
bitmex the og crypto derivatives
platform and the best place to buy your
bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
plan show so this podcast is sponsored
by the og crypto derivatives exchange
bitmex so bitmex has actually just
launched a brand new spot exchange so
now you can easily buy and sell many
different cryptocurrencies including
bitcoin on their exchange so if you do
want to use their exchange i'm going to
leave the information for you a link to
them in the description so definitely
pick bitmex as your number one exchange
also on this podcast we talk about all
the things that you're sort of not
allowed to speak about including
authoritarianism censorship freedom
bitcoin and all these things and so a
massive thank you to bit max because
without them we wouldn't be able to
bring you such important conversations
now before i kick the show off please
don't forget to hit the like button and
hit subscribe so you never miss a video
and also so that you can support these
very important conversations that we're
having joining me today is heidi the
host of the super popular youtube show
crypto tips heidi is an early bitcoin
adopter and also she's been through two
bear markets and three bull markets
let's kick this off hey leia it's great
to be here thank you so much for having
me let's talk about it yeah i'm really
excited there's so many interesting
things going on um i think your story is
really unique but before we get into all
of that i do want to learn a little bit
more um about you because this is the
first time we're meeting um you call
yourself an early adopter tell me what
that means how did you first hear about
bitcoin
um yeah so i first was introduced to
bitcoin in about 2014
late 2014 from the person who is now my
husband uh he actually
was trying to yeah inform me about it
and
through that just learning more and more
about
how a currency could exist outside of
the control of the government how it can
be valid and not
scammed and and duplicated and and all
that so uh it was a long journey of
education for me because i'm coming from
not a tech background not an uh
financial uh background either or
computer science so it was all really
new for me so
i mean
if you you want to talk about an early
adopter mindset what that means
basically i think anyone now can also be
an early adopter
i mean there's still plenty of people
around that are denying bitcoin that our
thing is still it's just a fad or for
whatever reason i think if you're like
surrounded by people who are putting it
down and yet you can still see the
potential in something despite having
this kind of uh confirmation bias
surrounding you
uh that's kind of like an early adopter
mindset you can have in a lot of
different things but including crypto
too
but you said that the way your now
husband
basically put this forward to you was
this money which is you know outside of
government control so
that's quite a libertarian and political
mindset so for you was it
you know the games was it the tech or
was it the political philosophy
um i mean obviously the gains is what
draws a lot of people in but for me um
also having this like kind of a nomadic
lifestyle thinking of a currency that
you can
hold and transact in across borders
without permission without having to
deal with banks in different countries
is very attractive as well
yeah definitely
the type of people who are interested in
bitcoin has evolved
from
the cypherpunks to the anarchists to the
liberal uh the the uh
other people who are you know
anti-government or whatever now it's
just people who are trying to hedge
against inflation and so
the narrative is constantly changing for
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies but uh yeah
so
yeah
before before we get into the whole
anti-government thing because for those
that don't know you run out to a u.s
citizenship which is mind-blowing to me
and i can't wait to ask you about that
um so stick around because we're gonna
get into that um but i wanna just get
your take on the markets um because you
know you have been through several
different cycles now um and a lot of
people say that this current cycle is
different to all the other cycles we've
seen because of all the institutional
money that's now involved um so what's
your take on where we're at
yeah i definitely agree with i know
willy woo was putting that out too how
over time the
uh the dramatic volatility of bitcoin is
going to be diminished and it makes
sense because as the market cap is
growing it takes
more heavier waves to to rock the boat
that is bitcoin so
also furthermore like okay 2000 again
let's go through like the different bull
runs
2012 and 2013
2014 that was uh again very small market
cap very little amount of money was
needed to to make that price go up and
same uh reverse 2017 was when mainstream
media was like pumping it out to people
and they were taking their investment
advice from
you know msnbc and fox news and and and
things like this and they weren't really
understanding why it was created and the
importance of it it was just like
the beginning of kind of meme coins for
cryptocurrencies so again it was really
shallow understanding of crypto and that
shallow understanding was represented in
how
how crazy the fomo was in 2017 2018 and
the reverse when it started backpedaling
when those uh irrational investors were
no longer there to support that type of
buying pressure um
so
uh
and now yeah what i said before it's
like we have countries having bitcoin as
legal tender we have publicly traded
companies that have bitcoin on their
books and they're doing so because they
trust bitcoin in a certain on a certain
level much more than they would with
their fiat or any other options they
would have for investing so it's a a
much more deeper understanding and a
trust and less speculation i think um
that we're seeing now so i i agree with
willy woo that it's gonna be less
dramatic of a of a blow off top you know
everyone was saying oh
2021 was that a blow off top i don't
think so um does that mean that this
bear market is going to be as long and
drawn out or as dramatic as we've seen
in the past as well who knows um
it's everyone wants to know everyone
wants to know what the crystal ball is
going to say for what the market is
doing
but
what i am constantly leaning on is the
long-term uh
you know prospects of bitcoin and what
it actually the utility that is bringing
to everyone you don't have to be an
accredited investor to buy bitcoin you
don't have to be an institutional
investor or you know you don't need any
credentials so
uh it's a pretty cool thing to see grow
and yeah uh the profits are still there
for sure but maybe not as dramatic as
before but let's so let's talk more
about the utility because you said that
you're 100 certain of bitcoin success
which is so funny because like to me
that's that's obvious but there's a lot
of people
who are heavily involved in in this
industry heavily involved in crypto who
just think you know it's all tech
um it's done it's finished um so how can
you be 100 certain of bitcoin's success
um it is the most okay so there's been
attempts at cryptocurrency since like
the 1970s with the cyberpunk movement
and they've been failing over and over
and over again and satoshi was the first
one to find the solution that didn't
revolve centralized control over the
network and that's what has has
you know bred this whole crypto space as
we know it um so bitcoin's been tested
since 2009. um and others
cryptocurrencies obviously it's been an
open source community and you can learn
from the mistakes and you can make
different trade-offs but
to say that even proof of stake is
tested and guaranteed is false in my
opinion that's arguably not true um
we haven't seen the proof of stake be
tested like bitcoin has and there's many
reasons for that just the way that the
consensus mechanism is different um
bitcoin if you hold a bunch of bitcoin
that doesn't that doesn't directly give
you a right to change how the network
functions proof of stake does so
that is very that is a very different
concept and something that people should
be paying attention to but yeah so
people who say like bitcoin is is old
tech
and they're gonna come out with like
this brand new solution like they have a
brand new consensus mechanism they did
something totally new it's so good for
marketing and for getting people excited
but when i hear that
i hear it's brand new it's untested it's
so
like we saw what happened with with ust
and with anchor protocol um we're seeing
what what's happening with solana that
was like the new ethereum killer in 2021
that blockchain's been down like 20
something times in the past year so
uh yeah it's it's a lot of i think eager
people
uh coming to the space but yeah i i feel
like i'm not i don't consider myself a
bitcoin maximalist that's about ascii
i'm happy to see a different crypt i've
invested in other cryptocurrencies
certainly
but
as time moves on i think more people
fall like realize the solidity that
bitcoin has and they lean back on that
and then you know they they still uh
well i can't speak for everyone but for
me personally um just kind of sprinkle
around a different cryptos and see what
happens
but what is but what does bitcoin's
success mean like
in what capacity do you would you say
okay that's been successful
the ability to transact freely in a
peer-to-peer fashion without censorship
uh
the incentive model for the bitcoin
network is in my opinion so solid um the
threat of overrunning the network from
any government from any one entity is
is out of the reach unless you know
you're going to print your fiat currency
into oblivion just to take over
the bitcoin network is kind of
ridiculous
um so yeah in my opinion
what it was put out for was for
peer-to-peer transactions and censorship
resistance and it has done that since
day one so um for me that's successful
so it's speaking of governments and
everything you you said that you think
that hang on i actually i actually have
the quote here you said
within a couple of years i predict that
bitcoin mining will be completely banned
in every single state in the us the
writing is on the wall um that was pr
you came down pretty harsh on that um
why do you think that the us is gonna
totally um you know ban bitcoin mining
um yeah i think that this is definitely
a representation of my mindset towards
the us generally that's why i made a
decision to pronounce as i did but it's
something like what we were seeing with
new york right they kind of teased it
that they were gonna ban bitcoin oh and
then they didn't and then uh some of the
the
lawmakers there were flipped and so now
they're deciding to actually pass the
bill on to uh
the the governor to sign it into law or
to veto it but so
it's
i don't know it the the us is such a
powerhouse that it is and bitcoin
equally such a powerhouse and how
disruptive it is
i am very skeptical that the us would be
copacetic with bitcoin um and yeah with
bitcoin mining i mean of course you can
mine bitcoin off the grid you can uh do
it anonymously but to for it to be
i don't know it could easily go the way
of china um and
and
i i'm just very i'm very skeptical and i
yeah probably just super pessimistic
about any kind of innovation coming from
the us at this point
yeah so let's talk about that you run
out your u.s citizenship which is so
wild because i'm
moving to the u.s i'm not becoming a
citizen um but i'm just moving there so
i can stay there longer than three
months um why did you renounce your u.s
citizenship
yeah well we're all making different
decisions based on where our lives are
taking us and for different reasons but
um
ever since i left the us the first time
i left the country
i found myself
wanting to live outside i don't know i
felt for example the first place i went
was portugal and that's where i live now
for most of the time for six months out
of the year and i felt more at home in
that country than i did in the home that
i grew up in and spent 25 years of my
life so that was the first kind of
fraction for me it was like
okay if i'm not going to live there
why would i
still be what what benefit is it for me
to have ties to a country that is uh
pretty
uh annoying to have to deal with uh for
paperwork if you want to bank outside
the us if you want to
sometimes if you want to invest in
different funds outside the us you're on
you aren't allowed to
um
with fbar and facta and all these things
it's like it's pretty annoying and
especially when you already know that
you're not interested in living there
it's really pointless not to mention the
fact that you can obtain second
citizenship
second passports that allow you to
travel to just as many if not more
countries that the us does
so i first obtained a second citizenship
in preparation for that change and then
yeah i i haven't regretted it since i
renounced in 2019
and uh
looking at how the us is going now i i
mean i should obviously mention
there's living outside the us and
there's also cryptocurrencies that was
like the number one and number two
reason i could see
again with regulations how they were
bottle-ducked and just like suffocating
the us citizens and their ability to
freely access cryptocurrencies um so
yeah there's i mean there's finance.us
versus binance.com there's some
even decentralized exchanges where if
you're identified as u.s citizen you
can't use it
if you wanted to invest in an ico or a
new project and you were a us citizen
you couldn't invest in it so for me it
was uh
that's like the main reason i'm so
excited
it's just for the crypto reasons but
yeah there's there's definitely a few
was it difficult because i heard that in
order to renounce you have to like
pay like crazy exit taxes and stuff like
that you don't have to get into too much
detail obviously
yeah no there's definitely uh depending
on your net worth at the time of
announcement you might have to pay
an exit tax which is basically a
percentage on everything that you own in
addition to that you are called a
covered expatriate and that means that
if you were ever to like send money to
family or to someone in the u.s that
would be taxed
or if your net worth was under a certain
threshold you just pay a regular you pay
your last tax as you normally would on
your income but there's no additional
tax on your total net worth
you do have to account for your total
net worth so they can determine if you
are a covered or uncovered expatriate
but that was pretty straightforward for
me i didn't fall under that threshold so
i didn't have to pay an exit tax um
thankfully the crypto was in a fair
market when i renounced
um
also i renounced in the bahamas which
was very
easy
and fast process
i i'm not sure what it is like now to
renounce with all of the
global lockdowns and the different i
think i've heard from a few people that
a few of the different us embassies
won't let you renounce unless you are a
resident of that country um so like for
example i wasn't a resident of the
bahamas but i just went there and i
renounced um and you do have to pay a
renouncement fee which i think it used
to be like seven hundred dollars and
then about five years ago they bumped it
up to
2300 or something like that um you can
pay cash or credit
but good to know
um that really blows my mind as well
because like i think um
you know even though i'm moving to the
states i still have an emotion i still
have an emotional connection to the uk
where i'm from um and so
i don't know i mean obviously it's
different like it's so different you
know you can be a resident of another
country and you still have to pay u.s
taxes being british you don't write like
that it's so easy you can go anywhere
and you know you're not followed or or
anything like that and for your money
but
did you not feel some kind of like
emotional
or like do you have any like identity
crisis because like that's overbought
you know you lived there for years like
was there no emotional difficulty in
doing that
i mean i really i don't want to speak
badly about where i come from and and
the town that i lived in but it was a
very small town very small town mindset
um a lot of people worked very hard for
very little money they're just scraping
by they're like living for the weekend
they're getting drunk at the at the bar
every weekend like it wasn't a very
inspiring place to be
so when i did step out of that and start
traveling i you know met so many other
people that were inspiring and healthy
and you know just like encouraging so
for me i felt i feel more of a tie to
other places than my hometown of course
i love my family who is still there
i see them frequently
as a renowned citizen you can still go
back to the us you just have to apply
for a visa just like everyone else is
not a us citizen basically
um but yeah so i didn't it wasn't as
much of an emotional thing for me uh
which i don't know maybe i have
something missing that didn't affect me
that much but i also had a very
supportive family that didn't try to
guilt me about anything like they were
very encouraging like listen i
understand you got to do what you got to
do we love you
and this is your life and it's amazing
so
yeah i've had a lot of encouragement so
that probably helped as well
that's amazing is your husband from the
same place or did you meet him like on
your journey
no he's from california too he renounced
about six months or yeah six to eight
months after me so
yeah that's crazy no i think that's so
fascinating um
the the contrast and like the difference
um is crazy but i i do understand it i
just i don't know emotionally i feel
like you do end up sort of
i don't know identifying with where
you're from so you have citizenship
where now then portugal
in saint kitts and nevis it's a
caribbean ah nice okay that's amazing um
so in times of adoption and you know
your issue with the us you said that you
think that it's going to come from a
federal level not at a state level
um sorry so to what
yeah can you hear me okay
yeah is it delayed
no no no you're good yeah okay so you
said that it's gonna come from a federal
level instead of a state level
um
so
what are the issues that you're seeing
on a federal level um in terms of crypto
obviously but i guess i'm also on a
broader
from kind of like a broader uh
perspective it might be interesting to
hear
well we're like what we're seeing for
example with grayscale in the sec or
what we're seeing with um the bank in
wyoming the name is escaping me right
now uh from caitlyn long her bank in
wyoming and they're suing the federal
reserve um
there's always going to be that glass
ceiling from the federal reserve from
the federal level because
that's where the money is that's what
they're protecting is their global
reserve currency in the us dollar um as
much as like the the states want to do
what they want to do like we're seeing
with caitlyn long and like they were
working great with the kansas city
federal reserve and then at a certain
point
the big fed stepped in and suddenly it's
been 19 months when normally it takes
five to seven days for them to make a
decision so um
yeah i think it is
it's like you know the american dream or
whatever the american way to have state
level governments but at a certain point
it's like you have a big brother that is
like the biggest brother of the world
that's gonna make sure it's gonna look
out for itself and it's gonna make
whatever narrative they can about crypto
to protect their special interests so
yeah unless you secede from the us or
something i'm very skeptical that you
can have a state
uh be fully as crypto free or whatever
as they'd like to be because you're
you're always gonna have to pay federal
taxes um and federal laws exist so yeah
that's what i was meaning by that
do you think that um america's always
had this big brother um or or do you
think at one point the american dream
was still was a reality and it's kind of
shifted
yeah i think it's i think the american
dream was reality until like the 70s
when you could have a thriving household
on one income now if
you know
two people working two jobs kids are
indica i mean we can go and tell how
it's dilapidated but um yeah i don't
think it's always been that way but uh i
think that the way technology has has
shifted and
certain things have happened around the
world and the way that they've kind of
taken advantage of those situations to
advance their power grabs uh
yeah i think it's it's become especially
apparent especially if you travel if you
travel to different countries you can
see how uh things are different i know
like the uk in london there's cctv like
every inch of the whole country
if you go to like the train stations
it's like you look like a
bunch of
yeah cameras pointing at you so um
yeah i'm probably getting off topic
there but no it's been
a big brother thing but
yeah
do you think that um
so obviously you're moving you're not
your u.s citizenship so do you think
that the
not all countries are going to be
hostile towards crypto but not just
crypto just general like this
authoritarian kind of um
this increase in like censorship
authoritarianism that we're seeing
globally um do you think that this is
going to be us only or are we going to
see this everywhere
i think okay so i remember i did a video
on this in like 2017 about crypto called
like the global flipping talking about
how some countries who have had it good
have had some kind of authority over how
the economies are are running around the
world and global trade have had it so
good for so long that yeah they're the
ones going to be disrupted and then
there's other countries that are just
waiting for the opportunity some kind of
a step up whatever shortcut they can to
get that that leg ahead and el salvador
uh we're seeing it in africa as well um
and so
and with covid or i'm sorry i shouldn't
say that but with the global lockdowns
that were happening
no red flags for the algorithm
with the global lockdowns that were
happening there was the countries that
were not so
strict with their regulations in that
regard and people were flooding there
because like mexico for example um and
there were countries like just with the
you know the required health
the juice
like some countries that re refused to
make mandates and some that did um so
and they've benefited from that so i
think that there's always if if a
country or government is hungry enough
or willing to go against the grain to a
certain point they will benefit and i
think i think what we're gonna see with
el salvador it's gonna be crazy since
even last year they adopted bitcoin and
their gdp grew by 10 for the first time
and not only just because they had
bitcoin on their books and it was like a
bull run but also because tourism is
coming in people want to go where people
can use their bitcoin and know that it's
friendly and have that experience and
actually integrate it into their life um
i know
in
in nevis uh one of the countries at
saint kitts and nevis uh they have like
it's everywhere bitcoin cash is
everywhere um
my lawyer who helped me get my
citizenship there she said she basically
pays for rent because her grocery is
everything in crypto so
yeah it's uh
it's gonna be i think a slow transition
uh to see what when these countries
really start popping up but absolutely
it's i don't think it's gonna be a
global thing there's of course there's a
world economic forum there's all these
like kind of global
uh powers that are going to try to keep
everyone in line but whether it's
actually enforced locally in that
country i think is has a lot of wiggle
room
so do you genuinely think there's going
to be this global flipping essentially
whereby the whereby america may not be
you know the big bad america anymore and
there could be
other countries which really
bring themselves onto the the financial
map they just basically get a c at the
table
i hope so yeah absolutely imagine an
economy built on
something like bitcoin where it's a
known cap supply inflation isn't a
threat you know exactly how much is
going to exist when and for whatever
reason um and
compared to you know oh we gotta print
this much money because whatever
decision we're gonna spend it here you
have no say in that whatsoever but
you're the victim of it through that
hidden tax that is inflation so uh yeah
i hope that they get shaken up i think
they've been on they've been top dog for
too long they've taken it for granted
and it's at the expense of the citizens
so
yeah but it's interesting because
this would you know you mentioned the
word economic forum and like there's
this whole narrative um being pushed
that bitcoin is you know either um bad
for the environment um it's uh supported
by lunatics
right-wing alt-right kind of illiterate
lunatics create every everything i think
even like i'm seeing things like um
people that go to the gym tend to be
more right-wing there's like this this
huge weird push
um that i'm seeing going on so why why
do you think that's happening um and
where do you think it's coming from
oh because they're scared that's why
they you know the narrative was always
oh bitcoin is for criminals even though
technically most people don't know how
to do bitcoin in a really and really
private manner so it's like
pseudo-anonymous basically so a lot of
criminals don't use bitcoin because it's
like very easily traced
um
but
and now actually the u.s treasury came
out with a report i'm not sure exactly
how long ago it's like it was within the
year saying that the uh amount of
transactions happening for illicit
activity on with bitcoin is like
a drop in the bucket like completely
minuscule compared to other traditional
financial uh tools like cash or whatever
banking
you name it but so um the narrative is
always changing and it's always because
it's a threat and
um the thing with the with the energy
consumption of bitcoin that is laughable
um if you do any research whatsoever
you'll learn that like 60 of bitcoin
mining is done with renewable energy and
not to mention the fact that um
there
this push for like
okay so it's really interesting what's
happening with ethereum and their move
from proof of work to proof of stake
it's really weird timing because it's
like falling in line with this esg
narrative that they're pushing so much
when in reality ethereum was planning
this since the day it was launched in
2015 it was planning to be proof of
stake and now it's like
it's like all of a sudden politically
correct as well um
but again this uh a lot of people think
like oh well what if bitcoin goes to
proof of stake some people who are
saying that i mean
anyone who who has really done their
research on bitcoin knows that's never
gonna happen
uh for many different reasons but
even that concept of using that
narrative oh it's it's more energy
efficient but again going back to what i
said about proof-of-stake how it's
different from proof-of-work is that
suddenly these whales
can change the network how it functions
can come together and change just
because they're holding a lot of bitcoin
um so i think it's really important to
have that separation of running the
network and interacting with it and the
coins involved so
um
yeah they're they're just gonna find
something to try to to try to scare
either that or or they're trying to push
down the price so then they can buy more
before it pumps again i don't know
uh yeah but
it's definitely coming from fear
but having by the way can you hear me
okay because i'm seeing comments that my
mic is isn't working very well so can
you hear me clearly
yeah you can hear me clearly okay so
guys let me know in the comments if you
can hear me i don't know what's wrong um
so
with all with all these like bizarre
narratives that are coming out um
apparently my mic is better now that's
great thanks guys um so with all these
bizarre narratives that's coming out um
it's so interesting because having these
conversations people often call you a
conspiracy theorist and they think
you're crazy
um and all this stuff and um i mentioned
this actually on a few episodes that a
few episodes ago that i did and um i was
talking to somebody at a party and i
said something like you know the
president joe biden he can't even string
a full sentence together and somebody
screamed to me was like you're a
conspiracy theorist and i'm like bro
like just watch a video
um
so how do you how do you like navigate
these ideas and this world and you're
trying to wake people up without being
called a conspiracy theorist and how do
you get people to take what you're
saying seriously
yeah it's definitely a balance between
you know not wasting your time and not
like throwing your pearls to the swine
you know what i mean like i i it's not i
i haven't made it my mission to like
convince everyone to think what i think
but uh
there are some red flags that i feel the
need to like just shut it out and then
if someone you know once
wants to understand it or look more into
it that's great um but yeah conspiracy
theorists are critical thinker i don't
know i feel like those are kind of
synonymous these days
uh
but you got to go back to also that
early adopter mindset like uh
you know
there's a lot of people who can see what
was happening with bitcoin and the
importance of it i mean also talk about
like okay talk about foresight and the
cypherpunk movement in 1993 eric hughes
wrote the cypherpunk manifesto if you
haven't read it i highly recommend it
these guys understood the importance of
encryption and protecting people's
privacy rights online through
communications that was in 1993 that was
like way before the internet took off
and that's the kind of foresight they
had
um and they volunteered their time they
weren't paid for this in any any way and
that movement eventually
culminated into the creation of
cryptocurrencies as well so you have to
you know
not count anything out
take it all with a grain of salt but
also be aware and see what is happening
and also be a little skeptical over why
certain things are going down the way
that they are um
i mean you don't have to go completely
crazy and like neurotic and like hide in
a bunker in your house or whatever but
like you can definitely also benefit
from trying to understand what's
happening and be strategic and flexible
in your life to to you know not get
taken out or you know
maybe possibly even benefit at the very
least not get taken out you know
yeah and this this whole conversation
sort of goes further than i know
everything is about money but it goes
further than that because i know a lot
of americans are having issues with um
like the the farmland now which is
totally being bought up by um bill gates
um i saw that um i think a chicken farm
or something was totally burnt down the
other day um and that was like owned by
a family or something and that had that
had been around for like decades and has
always been fine um so like food is is a
really big topic i wondered if you had
any thoughts on farming and food or
anything like that
i it's a skill that i feel like i should
learn
like everyone should learn
just in case something happens also just
like you know understanding where your
food is coming from i'm really health
conscious and you know try to eat as
organic as possible whenever i can um
but
yeah obviously food is whatever you're
talking about if something has intrinsic
value it goes down to food it boils down
to that um that's where you like you
know sustenance so yeah uh
this whole concept i know i don't know
how familiar are with like the world
economic forum and their
ideas of like you know we're gonna eat
bugs and like just completely chemically
created meat or something i don't know
the more that they push that thing the
more you want to go the other way um and
there's so many
hypocrisies in
the members of that forum and
and they're versus what they're putting
out for example bill gates he flies his
private jet all over the place like and
he's
preaching about saving the environment
and things so
yeah uh
i i'm very skeptical that they're
actually looking out for our own
self-interest and not just trying to
push whatever they can for their own
reasons so
i won't be eating any bugs unless it's
by accident
how do you um how do you find yourself
like so sure of these things um because
again it always comes back to that
conspiracy theorist thing um like i'm
aware of what's going on with um the
world economic forum um i know the whole
bug narrative um but whenever i speak to
people who aren't in my bubble um or my
echo chamber um they always think it's
so crazy like i had a family member
around for um dinner last night and um i
was talking about bill gates and i was
sort of saying you know um well if he
really cared about the environment he
wouldn't have his short position on
tesla did you see the text that he sent
elon musk and i'm getting like really
and my family and my family members just
like what no bill gates like totally
cares about the environment and you know
he's doing
i don't understand like why
some people don't see it so clearly
i think it's a lack of
uh investigating on their part i think a
lot of people outsource their their
critical thinking to other people or
they just don't want to believe that
there's
such a prevalent boogeyman right in
front of them that's actually really
controlling everything about their life
the past two years should have been a
shining example of that um
there's i mean
i don't want to get into that whole
concept conversation of what happened
the past two years because that can be
very
touchy but
i think it's a perfect example of how
extreme things can get um and
yeah uh
whenever i think of like people like
you're saying they don't believe you or
whatever i my
unfortunate like you know my skepticism
is like well just wait and see like it's
okay like
i don't have to be right you don't have
to be right we'll just wait and see and
i'm in the meantime i'm going to be as
strategic strategic as i can with my
life decisions where i invest my money
where i live where i travel to my health
decisions um
and
you can follow their narrative and see
how it goes for you but for me
personally it's like i find much more
comfort in my own knowledge and my own
independent research than whatever's is
being
spoon-fed to me you know from whatever
source it's like facebook or social
media or whatever they tend to be very
emotional about arguments and actually
if you
most people if you find that they
they're like okay uh i like bill gates
if you ask like okay well what do you
what does he do specifically that you
like they don't know they can't say
anything they just know that they heard
somewhere sometime he's a good guy or
something or whatever so and take that
concept to like all these other things
that people should be questioning but
they don't it's very surface level
belief that they have and if you just
ask a simple question why what do you
think about what this happened and they
don't know or
it's just yeah
and maybe that question that you asked
is good enough to send them on their way
down that rabbit hole to do their own
research and you've done a good job
so where so where do you think this
whole thing is going um because i know
you've spoken a bit about cbdc's i try
and talk about cbdc's as much as
possible um
you know by 2030 you'll have nothing and
you'll be happy bugs and all that great
stuff
where
it's so freaky it's literally like a
james bond movie it's like a if it's
where clash rob is a real james bond
villain but um
where is this all going
um
yeah
cbdc's are such a scary thing for me to
think about how easy it will be for them
to to force that on people
um but actually toby had a really good
point um we were talking about this the
other day my husband toby he was saying
that uh
they're trying it could be that like all
these regulations that are being put on
crypto through
they they use excuses like what happened
with luna and oh my gosh stable coins
need to be regulated they need to be
identified you need a kyc if you want to
do a stable coin because it's in your
best interest and so they're trying to
kind of regulate crypto in such a way
that it it's going to be kind of
synonymous with how a cbdc is going to
be functioning so they're kind of like
getting you used to
uh interacting it because if it wasn't
regulated and it was totally free you
could only you know you could do a
open a crypto account with just a web
with just an email and password like you
used to be able to do um and
now they try to
bring in a central bank stable coin that
has all these different hiccups and
control and lack of privacy and it's not
a public blockchain and you can't see
where your transaction is going to but
they can
um
it would be such a stark difference that
people with any ounce of a brain would
choose the other option rather than a
cbdc and you know
the free market would kind of win out in
that way but yeah i in the long term
it's going to be
probably
surface level if you have to interact
with a cbdc you do so at a minimum
or you're completely off the grid and
you're all in the seedy underbelly of
decentralized privacy coins and
cryptocurrency
um
it sounds so orwellian when i'm
describing this whenever i think about
it i had someone we do an ama and i had
someone ask me
15 years from now let's say you're still
living in the u.s and let's say
they've banned bitcoin and
you've never sold bitcoin and you're
ready to retire
uh what do you do with crypto and i was
like you go to a different country
that's adopted bitcoin and he lives
happily ever after there like
at what point like that's
at what point is it worth it to live in
a country and contribute to that country
with your paying taxes um that
you you have this like moment where like
uh nomad capitalist always says go be
your treated best i think that's a great
saying to have and live by um
but yeah i mean i understand there's
people who are patriotic i understand
there's people who have family and ties
and for whatever reason they can't leave
but when push comes
comes to shove at certain point you have
your limits and
i wasn't willing to wait to see how bad
it gets before i left uh that might be
but it you know i had other places to go
that i'd rather go anyway so it worked
out but
yeah not to get to doomsday on here but
i think there's definitely going to be
two worlds of cryptocurrency
and the people who know about bitcoin
now
are great they're they're they have such
such a a heads up and step in the right
direction of understanding how to
interact with crypto freely how to have
your own wallet how to use a
decentralized exchange
um
and just really simple things like that
because now you know we have paypal
coming into crypto we have
uh
so many wallet providers that
uh for d5 i've done i've been trying to
find research of like wallets outside of
metamask that you can use and so many of
these these wallets advertised they
market themselves as being user-friendly
oh if you forget you don't have to worry
about your seed phrase if you forget
your password we can get it back because
they're the ones holding the seed like
you don't have real ownership but they
don't say that and so people who are
coming in like that's been my mantra and
basically how i have this channel is
like just to remind people like no this
is how you should do it i know how
convenient that is
but i believe in your ability to learn
this i believe in your ability to to do
this the right way so
it's important and
you said go where you're treated best so
you're in portugal so i'm really
interested to know what life is like in
portugal do you have like other
like-minded people is there a big crypto
community and then i also saw that there
was going to be some regulation or
something on taxes but that didn't pass
yeah so
i we moved to portugal in 2015.
that was before they made any
announcement being crypto friendly or no
taxes on crypto we moved to portugal
because the low cost of living the high
quality of life surfing the food the
people oh my gosh the people at the
locals are amazing so i love portugal it
feels like home for many different
reasons um and then in was it 2017 or
2018 they said they weren't going to tax
crypto and
and it's been that way for several years
until this year
i think they had
the left side more in their governments
and so they're pushing for taxes
and
i think there was some misinformation on
what happened it was about a month ago
uh
i guess
okay because i have a lawyer in portugal
and so she's into crypto and she's like
it's in her best interest to know
exactly what's happening here so she
told me how
um
there was this meeting that they were
going through this agenda to discuss
with the finance minister and at the end
of the meeting it was an unofficial
question this guy just off-handedly say
hey are we going to tax crypto and he
said the finance minister said uh
listen there's been a
a study that was requested last year it
hasn't been completed yet let alone we
haven't analyzed it yet um if and when
you know that happens we will analyze
and make a decision he refused to give
any timeline of when it was going to
happen and then shortly after that i
think the left side was was putting up
to vote to approve some taxes for crypto
and it was denied so
i don't think it's going to last forever
being tax free and crypt uh for uh
portugal
but uh i mean enjoy it while you can if
you are here but speaking of the people
who are coming into portugal
specifically for crypto yeah there's
been a lot of in uh all over the place
actually lisbon um there's these cafes
and workspaces where it's all crypto um
there's no crypto exchange
oh it's frozen i don't know if that's
just
guys can you let me know if it's me or
if it's heidi that's frozen
oh can you hear me heidi uh yeah can you
hear me now yeah i don't know if you if
it was you or me that phrase but i can
hear you now it might have been mine
i think it was my wife that's good so
far
i'm surprised i'm surprised my mic has
been so terrible honestly that's what
i'm surprised about i thought it was
okay
um but go on sorry you you were saying
like you don't think it's gonna last but
right now um it's good for people to to
come
yeah i mean yeah
i i think that you should have an
understanding that if you're coming here
specifically just because it's crypto
free
there's there's this whole concept of
like okay it's crypto friendly
it can either mean that there's zero
regulations but those regulations could
come in the future which is what
portugal is right now or there's really
clear regulations you know what you're
going to be paying and it's solidified
in law and it's also a pretty small tax
that's like the best uh you know uh
crypto friendly friendliness so portugal
it's not regulated so
it could go either way so if you're if
you're trying to you know base your life
based on
uh where you're going to be paying your
taxes for crypto um it might be short
lived in portugal but there's lots of
other reasons to move to portugal too
it's an awesome country but not trying
to shill portugal too hard i can't help
it no it's cool i i see portugal in my
future at some point i see at some point
in my life if you do you got to let me
know we gotta i'll show you around i
will do no 100 i will um
but where so if portugal has these taxes
potentially coming um where are you
bullish on long term um how successful
do you think el salvador is going to be
um i know they have their um
no income tax no capital gains tax on
bitcoin and all this stuff so um yeah
what are your thoughts on that yeah um
i'd be here to see how their volcano
mining turns out as well i know they put
that project on hold because it didn't
quite time out with a bull market which
we review is kind of weird like you
should just maybe you know push that
either way i think it's a good thing to
do but
um yeah i'm i'm pretty i mean talk about
crypto being an experiment that's an
experiment as well yeah they've already
benefited from it um i think there's
they're gonna be obviously feeling what
it is to have such a volatile
uh asset as their legal tender but i
think generally over time just like with
any kind of investment in bitcoin
generally over time we're gonna do
really well
um so i'm interested to see how they
continue to build out their
infrastructure and how that's surrounded
by crypto and also how the locals feel
about it um
usually when a country is trying to you
know create more wealth or stimulate
some kind of tourism
unfortunately it's at the expense of the
locals like these new you know crypto
rich people come in and the the prices
of property are skyrocketing all of a
sudden the locals can't even afford to
be there anymore so hopefully there's
some kind of
regulation to protect them as well or to
benefit them specifically so
uh that's what i'd be looking for um
yeah also i think dubai is kind of an
interesting one to see how that's
developing oh i disagree with you on
that one
i'll go i'm sorry you you speak
just that they're like you know tax-free
and crypto friendly
i don't know my thing with dubai is like
it's so inauthentic
like the whole place is just like this
is
the whole thing is so inauthentic so
like i don't for a second believe
that it's pro crypto because like for me
like what is pro crypto like what is pro
bitcoin it's like freedom
independence um
but like in dubai i think
when someone just snaps their fingers
you know
you could have that taken away easily so
i just don't i just don't trust i just
don't trust
that the intentions are good for me the
whole that whole thing with dubai so
inauthentic i just feel really weird
about it well that's good we'll keep an
eye on that one we'll see how it
develops
but portugal i want to come to el
salvador i'm really um intrigued um do
you think the rest of latin america are
going to follow yeah well there's a lot
of interest yeah yeah from other
countries in south america um
and what was it oh it's escaping me
jamaica was like doing gonna be the next
to launch a cbdc or something that's not
the same thing obviously
but uh yeah i think
i think uh
there's probably countries now that are
waiting to see like okay so el salvador
like stepped out right right okay we're
gonna do it and then it's a bear market
so people are gonna feel like okay we'll
see ya we'll see how they do and then if
they can come out on top okay we'll
we'll back that up as well but
yeah uh
it's it's pretty exciting times to be
able to to see this and
uh to have the freedom of flowing
information that we have now compared to
say like you know even 30 years ago with
the internet like it's pretty cool to to
to be able to watch this unfold in a
probably the most honest way that we
could possibly understand how it's
happening
yeah no i totally agree with you it's an
insane time to be alive i mean we spoke
at the beginning of conversation about
the american dream being dead but in my
eyes this is sort of like the new
american dream but it's like the global
dream it's like the individual dream um
and so yeah i think it's fascinating to
to watch it all play out um but heidi
how can people follow you see what
you're up to your youtube channel like
show yourself how can people get in
touch with you yeah so we post videos
every day on youtube it's crypto tips i
don't know if they say my little name
tag there it's the same thing that we
have there um on twitter it is
blockchain chick
check the spelling scammers are
everywhere
um
yeah we also have a we have a patreon
group called the ct club i just go to
patreon.comcryptotips i'm on instagram
to oh i'm sorry why i'm on tiktok i'm
trying out that are you on tick tock yet
yeah i want to take talk it's a weird
experience but i'm slightly addicted to
it it's actually very good
yeah we're on tick-tock it's real crypto
tips because someone already took our
name of course but yeah you can find us
there
that's perfect guys please go follow
heidi it's so great to see people who
are so awake to everything that's going
on right now the youtube channel is
pretty amazing um so many amazing crypto
tips as the name says so heidi thank you
so much for coming on it's been such a
pleasure having you
yeah thank you leia it's been great
absolutely and guys please don't forget
to hit the subscribe button um so you
never miss a video and i think my mic
kind of cut out at the beginning so i
just want to let you know this is
sponsored by bitmex they are an og
crypto exchange they've just launched an
amazing spot exchange platform so
if you do want to join them the
information is in the description so go
check them out so we will see you all
next week and thank you so much for
tuning in bye bye
ohio pancho
you